um
so i'm daniel lathrop i work at the
dallas morning news uh for another
couple of months after that i'm going to
be teaching at the university of iowa
journalism school
where my hope is to put out a new
generation of reporters who can program
and do math
because one of the biggest problems that
we have if you read any mainstream
news site
consume any mainstream media is that
journalists are largely enumerate
and and i think personally it's
been my mission to change that which is
why i'm
i'm ditching
ditching the better paying world of
print journalism which is not a
well-paying world
for the even less well-paid world of
academia uh
but
academia has its own benefits like i can
work on what i want
and
and if i do a really good job for the
next six years i may get tenure and that
would be pretty cool
uh
so
i'm going to talk a little bit about
what we've been doing at the dallas
morning news uh to try to make both make
our journalism more numerate using
python and to make our reporters more
numerate
oh okay well we'll wait for a moment
then uh
oh okay
um
so uh
i guess we'll we'll wait just a minute
and see if any we get any other
customers uh in the meantime does
anybody i'm just curious why people are
here if you're here just because you
were in this room before and you just
didn't want to move hands
okay you're interested in journalism
okay
uh you're
curious about what the heck a journalist
would do with python yeah okay
uh
those are those are those are good
reasons to be here um
so i'm going to talk
a little bit about um
to start with about class that we did
the dallas morning news newsroom has 300
people
which is one of the largest newsrooms in
the country
there are
a handful the new new york times the la
times that have larger
uh newsrooms uh we
uh
and there's no other than national news
organizations like the new york times
and the la times uh the associated press
reuters et cetera
there really aren't
any news organizations out there that i
know of that have newsrooms much bigger
than us
you know
at a scale now
in the world before craigslist and
before the internet
uh
the dallas morning news had 800 person
newsroom uh because we had a monopoly on
local on a large chunk of local
advertising and we charged a lot of
money for it and
our customers didn't love that but they
needed to reach our readers and so they
they gave us a lot of money
that has
not been true
the
print newspaper industry has seen
declines in advertising revenue
year over year every quarter for
basically the past decade without a
single with uh
and without a single quarter of
improvement for at least the last at
least since um 2003.
um
so anyhow uh
this is that's all a way of saying uh we
still have more journalists than anybody
else but uh we also have fewer people
than we used to and uh
uh
not being laid off is the new raise in
journalism
so
i was really pleased when we sent out a
note not a very encouraging note
actually to our newsroom that said
basically we're going to do a class on
programming in python we'll teach you
how to scrape
a website and the basics of a
programming language and it didn't
really say much more than that and i had
told my boss when i planned to send this
email that six people would sign up and
i knew who they were and instead 60
people signed up
uh
and it included future writers that
included um
it included copy editors that included
uh graphic artists
designers
pretty much
assignment editors the people who are
bosses of reporters
a lot of people who i never would have
guessed would be interested
and the reason for that
was that
journalism is in a tremendous period of
transition and everybody gets
finally
that and it's taken a long time for
people to get their heads there that
they can't keep doing things the same
old way and this seemed like
maybe an approach uh that we could take
so
we
have with these slides that we put up
and if anybody's interested they're at
datalab.dallasnews.com
uh
i'm not going to go through these
obviously it's pretty basic
and we spent six weeks and we had a
dropout rate of
66
and
two-thirds percent
which
was better than when we found out 60
people were signing up was
a lower dropout rate than i thought it
would be because i still thought only
six people were going to get through the
class and i knew who they were
uh those six people did all make it
through the class i'm very pleased my my
plan to teach them python worked
but
along the way what i discovered
was that python is actually
a great way to teach people who are not
really quantitative thinkers about
quantitative thinking
and uh
and and that was a great
discovery for me uh because i've been
trying uh for a decade to teach
reporters who are not
geeky like me
how to think quantitatively
and
this in teaching them
python and teaching them a little bit
about programming and teaching them just
enough to scrape some basic websites
uh
i saw the lights go off in people's eyes
and they and i've seen the difference in
their journalism
already and i think there's a lesson
in that for other organizations
that have
a lot of people in them who
really should be thinking more
quantitatively more analytically
that actually python in particular
because it is very rigid you have to do
things exactly the right way and there
really is one right way to do it
got people thinking
in a in a different headspace in a
different way and they didn't have to be
people who were who wanted to be
developers who wanted to be programmers
who wanted to be analysts
they really
really worked with writers
writers are about as far
as you can get
from computer scientists
in terms of personality type
particularly newspaper reporters who
tend to be
or reporter writers who tend to be
outgoing
they spend their life talking to people
and
although they are smart so they're not
totally the opposite you have to be
smart to be a reporter well you have to
be smart to be a good reporter you can
anybody can be a bad reporter uh i can
teach you to be a bad reporter in an
afternoon
so that's
that's sort of one piece of what we've
been doing and i'm really pleased that's
just sort of sharing with people about
it you know we
started off
with a very basic plan which was that we
were going to teach people to scrape
one
website
and in six weeks we were able to take
people from nothing to scra in python to
scraping
a website and getting the
salary information of every player in
the nfl uh we started with the dallas
cowboys
in like week three and worked our way up
till uh we actually were exporting it to
a reasonably useful csv file
i am waiting to see somebody in our uh
somebody do something with that but none
of our sports writers were in the class
so
it's my expectation that that that
probably won't happen but
uh it also paid dividends and this is a
lesson i think
for any organization
that is not primarily a technical
organization
uh that is great one of the writers at
the paper
uh he covers the city of irving
uh
folks here who are from the dfw area
yeah okay so the city of irving has this
crazy mayor who's decided that the big
issue facing the city of irving uh which
is an interreg suburb uh facing the
challenges that inter-ring suburbs face
like uh changing demographics
uh like uh
infrastructure that is now reaching an
age where maintenance costs are suddenly
going way up from where they had been
because it was all new
uh
sharia law naturally that's the big
issue facing irving according to the
mayor and she's she's nuts
um
and one of our reporters has been
covering this nutty mayor
and uh
he does not say she's nuts he's very
objective about the whole thing
i don't cover them i think she's nuts
and
and so he decided he was going to
monitor her facebook page
see what she was doing on her facebook
page and see particularly if she was
deleting things she'd said and deleting
comments
now
traditionally the way newspaper
reporters do this would do this is they
would go to the person's web page every
day and look through it and see if they
saw anything different
he had been in our class and so he
thought
there's a better way
i'm going to write a scraper and he
taught himself how to
using
some libraries that other people had
already built how to go in and uh pull
down everything from her page using
uh facebook api and diff it and see what
was new and
uh what had been added and what had what
had gone away
and he said you know in the end he did
not find a great story out of that but
he did now have a way to monitor what
was going on with her or any other
facebook page of somebody that he
covered
and that's the kind of transformation
that i think
can apply to
any organization it can apply to a bank
it can apply
to uh
could apply to
i always think of banks as being not
like what we do
it can apply to you know a restaurant
supply company you can apply
to anybody because
now i have
a bunch of people in my newsroom 20 who
finished the class 60 who got part of
the way through it
who know
just enough to do really simple things
themselves without asking me
which makes
which means that
i and my team
and other technical teams at the paper
can now spend more time working on
harder things
harder more interesting things
and the other thing is they now see the
possibilities and they now understand a
lot more about what can be done
and we're getting
lots of people who were in the class and
who weren't in the class saying oh we'd
really like to do this we would really
like to scrape and monitor the dallas
county civil courts
to see when these kinds of things happen
and the best thing about that was
we were able to get that request from
somebody who wasn't in the class but had
heard about the class and heard about
what people were doing
and then we were able to get someone who
was in the class to volunteer to write
the scraper
which means that not only did we
do we
uh create awareness in the organization
of the kinds of things that we can do
did we get people thinking
quantitatively and analytically instead
of like well i'll just go through the
civil courts and see if there's anything
interesting
which is the typical journalistic way to
approach monitoring a civil court docket
just look at it
huh i recognize that name that might be
interesting
um and uh then we also had somebody uh
non-technical not primarily technical to
outsource the work to uh
which again means that my team
gets the benefit of
increasing our mission within the
newsroom and at the same time still
getting to spend most of our time on
more interesting problems
uh
i guess i should also show you
uh i would say within journalism that's
my that's my inspirational story i hope
i hope i hope you liked it i hope you
can
take it back uh if you do work in a
non-technical organization uh
to to that um this is our github
repository
we have
uh
most of this is either front-end stuff
in javascript
or back-end stuff in python or scripts
that we've built in python we
within journalism i would say most
people who do what i do
data journalism work
primarily or at least partially in
python
there's obvious reasons for that python
is
the best general purpose language uh
that spans two dimensions
that those of us who do what i do in
journalism usually spend a lot of time
in one is
web development
either for the public or in particular
with me internal tools
tools for myself even
and then
more importantly
analysis
the ability to do
high-level analysis in a language that
also has that general purpose is
i think really transformative it's why
we wanted to teach python to people in
our news organization
because
as opposed to if they were to go learn r
to do more statistical work or spss
or sas or any statistical programming
package
or language
you get that in python and for free
you get a general purpose
language
that can do
any number of things that can scrape a
website that you can use
to build something in django or flask
and so you see a lot of this uh
you know amounts to
building just building tools this is
something i made recently uh it's a
django thing
to let people upload a data set and then
use it and then edit it in the django
admin
so
was not a incredibly complicated project
it's a huge benefit for me in my
newsroom
because now i can take any reporter who
has a data project
and instead of saying okay
here's an excel spreadsheet
start entering stuff into it whatever
you do
don't end don't don't enter text into
these fields that i want to be numbers
don't i have data validation a date is
always a date
a string is always a string
i can do
i can do
i can we can we can do geo fields and
it's not just random address that we
hope will geocode they get the map they
can go up and drop the point
they can enter the address
and see the point and see the point
that's getting plotted and fix it if
it's wrong
which is has been a
already a really good thing and i'm
hoping will
translate into more more interesting
more quantitative more interactive uh
products from the dallas morning news
in the next in the next year or two
years um
let's see
all right that's 20 minutes
so i'm going to take questions uh
in just uh just a few minutes um
before that i would like
uh to show off uh
talk a little bit about uh journalism uh
journalism's relationship with python
just a little bit longer
i think there's if you follow tech and
journalism there's a site called
source
and it's
it's run by a program called open news
which was started by mozilla
and
by the knight foundation which is
the biggest non-profit funder of
journalism stuff knight foundation was
started by the knight brothers who owned
the miami herald they became very rich
and they didn't like their kids so they
left all the money to a foundation
and what we would what journalis they
are
probably the only organization funding
serious r d
in journalism other than the new york
times
which
has a large r d department
but like a lot of r d departments at
non-technical organizations their r d
department doesn't seem to produce a lot
of things that actually make their way
into the product but they make lots of
cool stuff
if you
follow source religiously as as i and
you know the hundred two hundred other
people who do what i do
within journalism do you see that almost
everything that's going on on there is
being done in python
except for the stuff that's being done
that's front end related uh and
obviously until we have python in the
browser
uh
brython project big big plug for them
hopefully some someday we will all be
able to abandon javascript
uh
and and that ranges from the new york
times to small newspapers django web
framework itself was actually built at a
small newspaper originally
and so
the lawrence uh the lawrence
nebraska
world uh
and uh yeah they
they decided they
they built um
the the very you know it was when they
released it it was django 0.5 i think
i i used it back then it was already
awesome because it had that admin and
that was like so
saved my life so many times
uh so let's uh from there let's do
questions
oh yeah sure
so let's see
source open
news
ah there we go
yeah see that's what i get for yahoo
i apologize other questions while i try
to find this website that i usually go
to i'm not
let's see how did you become a data
editor how did i become a data
editor um that is an excellent question
i
started off
as
i'm sorry this is just
so i started off as a police and courts
reporter
at
um
at a small town newspaper in iowa which
is how
once upon a time was the traditional
starting point for a journalist you sort
of worked at a small newspaper and then
a slightly bigger newspaper and then a
slightly bigger newspaper and someday if
you made it through that windowing
process you ended up at a really big
newspaper like the dallas morning news
this is the convention
uh
open news
opennews.org of course
and
from
source
oh just a second i'm just gonna do
from the open news
all right
all right
anyhow this is
a lot of the interesting stuff
open news is
yeah
the vlog's the
vlog here this is the thing so
um
and a lot of this stuff lately is about
the big source source con convention
because that's coming up and all the
deadlines are
so
you know as your organization becomes a
little more tech savvy
a little tech savvy let's not even need
to say a little more tech savvy
leadership uh who
makes uh decisions about
how the business is going to continue to
produce value and how it's going to
survive
in the changing world
do they
do do they see new opportunities with um
doing things with data doing things with
maybe providing apis
repackaging data
so the answer is yes um
the dallas morning news
which is the oldest business in texas
oldest continuously operated business in
texas founded during the
republic of texas
not
not this newfangled united states of
america
recently hired a
new editor-in-chief
he's the first editor-in-chief hired
from outside the staff of the paper in
35 years
he is a man named mike wilson
his most recent job before this was as
the managing editor of 538.com
which is
you know nate silver's
site
so
let's see 530a with the little fox
um
which is all about uh data
data analysis data visualization
um
so uh that's the direction our publisher
clearly is going um
is also been it's the reason i've been
there for
six years it's the reason i have a team
of people
we
we actually are already creating
products
that are profitable that that have added
to the bottom line
the most
boring
but profitable
of which
is
this best
neighborhood
wow
there we go all right
which is our neighborhood comparison
site
this allows you to
based on a variety of data points or not
uh
wow
look to that
uh anyhow it lets you we have sliders
you can come up with a list uh based on
uh data we collected about neighborhoods
we
we've been doing this project for three
years now
it has made the company and the
aggregate over that time well over half
a million dollars
which since that's far in excess of the
cost of
my team over that time
puts us as a profit center
just
alone as a profit center
we're about to launch a new
version that will hopefully
not have whatever problem it is that's
causing it not to load today
uh
you know on may 15th
and
it's
what we've done is we've collected
quantitative data about everything from
crime
to the percentage of people who own pets
and then
we
used a
fairly basic statistical analysis to
create
ranges and z-scores
for each of those
each of those things
we index them up into a set of 11
indexes
and
then we weight the in terms of what we
produce is sort of a
for the you know the the top line here
are the top 10 places to live
uh we did a poll like a real survey poll
of
amber alert
sorry um
of the dfw area for what people care
about and a place to live uh it was a
stacked
stacked preference
and so we were able to do percent of
preference
and then the sliders lets people
uh
do that for themself uh
so
uh
that's the i guess that's a very long
way of saying that's an example of the
kind of products we're trying to create
and we're trying to build
is that
has the additional benefit of being in a
very sweet spot for us which is that it
it fulfills a serious reader need
uh
has great reader interest
and also is
uh really um
really attractive to advertisers the
print section that we're doing on it
uh recently closed and we sold more
advertising in it than we had budgeted
for
which doesn't sound that impressive
except
i work in an industry
where
the amount of advertising has declined
year over year for the better part of a
decade
uh
so huh
uh other questions
yeah so um so that type of project
requires uh public data sources i
suppose
how how many of those are from
government municipal and how many of
them do you have to build yourself
and curate
well uh
so
for that project
we
there are a number of the data sets that
are
mosaics
uh like
the first several years our crime data
was a mosaic i went and collected it
from half a dozen different sources
uh
and it stored it in half a that stored
it well
no it was more than half a dozen sources
there's about a dozen sources uh and
that was only because one thankfully
the north central texas council of
governments was gathering already
gathering crime data from a lot of uh
a lot of uh
municipal and county police agencies but
uh unfortunately
they
those were then themselves already
stored in a variety of different you
know there was one data format but the
actual
semantic content of the data and what
things that were in the meant was
still different from small town to small
town
you know
we gathered
i'll say this we didn't create any of
our own
we created a bunch of our own data sets
for it
which are
searchable in terms of at the
neighborhood level through this tool and
will be more so and the one that we're
about to release
we've talked about putting it out there
as an api
the
biggest barrier to which is that
some of what's in there is proprietary
data that people provided to us
for free because they get they thought
it was a valuable service for the public
but exposing their data
as part of that
without charge would mess with their
business model and i don't
i
i didn't really sign any licensing
agreements on it so the technically
speaking there's no reason that we
couldn't but it would be really low rent
uh
but most of it is either primarily from
government or secondarily from
government so it's
for example
esri the big
gis company has provided us a fair
amount of data
that is their own or that they've
purchased
projections based on census data so that
we could
uh and a census and then other public
data so
you can do projections on things like
what areas are likely to be experiencing
uh high growth in property values which
is of course something that is of great
interest to people
yeah so what do you think are the
biggest blockers for more data-driven
journalism is it the fact that your
fellow journalists are immigrants or
the fact that putting these data sets
together
in the labor or just going and getting
that
um i think the biggest
the biggest barrier to it is that most
news organizations
um
haven't figured out what the role of it
is in their business
you have this sort of crop of new
startups like 538 and vox
that are putting sort of data the upshot
at the new york times data and data
analysis at the center
of their news product and it's a core
part of what they do
for a legacy news organization like the
dallas morning news
traditionally our
value add to our customers has been
we'll tell you what's happening at your
local city council meeting
we'll
we'll tell you
what whether the cowboys won or lost
we'll tell you
a lot of those kinds of things
and to the extent that we do really big
analytical stuff
it translates into really big the sort
of
so my job is my position my team are
part of the investigative projects team
because that was the place in the
organization that kind of could figure
out what to do with us like oh you work
on things for a long time and they're
really cool you must be an investigative
projects reporter
and
a lot of my work actually does
does involve that
does involve investigative work which is
where
a lot of the data journalism
at most news organizations is hiding
it's hiding in those big investigative
packages
the truth is that uh
that that's the biggest barrier is that
news organizations
really
haven't yet
figured out
how to reinvent
themselves
to provide people
different kind of information
than they have in the past which is
really funny
because news organizations have
reinvented themselves over and over
again in just the 20th century and
sort of basic data journalism
has been uh
is a point that i like to make to other
journalists
has been one of the the core things for
a lot of news organizations the new york
times best seller list
what is that
just
they collect data from book sellers
and tabulate it to find out what books
are selling the most
the dow jones industrial average started
by
the wall street journal
recently sold
i believe to morningstar for more money
than news corporation is worth
or the wall street journal
was worth once it was sold let me say
that um
uh
let's see uh the
the uh in sports
you know those number one schools
they're the number one team in
basketball and football
the number that is generally being cited
there uh is uh either a coaches poll or
a sports writer's poll done by the
associated press
data journalism uh
but we haven't uh
we haven't
i mean i would say we haven't
figured out the
uh
enough things like our best
neighborhoods
uh that where we can uh
we can build local franchises around
it you don't need data journalism to say
what happened at city hall last night
okay
you do you don't but you do need data
journalism uh you do need data
journalism to help you determine whether
whether that matters
and and i will say within sort of
investigative and enterprise journalism
journalists do a very good job
uh by and large of
uh either being able to work with data
on their own most news organizations
have people like me
who will work with them
on
on making sure that people can do
you know
get a spreadsheet of the road of the
street conditions and we'll tell you and
we can you know it's easy to figure out
you know which areas have you know the
most have the worst streets and easy to
figure out things like oh look the
streets next to the members of the city
council are always great
i think we do we do a better job of that
also than we really surface to our
readers
yeah
um
yeah so
i will say this uh pegasus
uh
was acquired by the dallas morning news
a few years ago uh we acquired them
mostly
uh for their uh listings
uh
th their their their uh their tool for
gathering and surfacing event
event listings
uh
the people some of the people that we
brought over from pegasus are
at the core
of this which is the relaunch of the
dallas morning news's
dallas morning news is
essentially entertainment arts and
entertainment coverage
arts entertainment dining
and you can see a lot of the
content that is now coming out of this
is directly out of that pegasus database
20 things to do this weekend
five uh on the news side the answer is
no
on the news side uh
we uh we never really
um
so it's all good yeah i mean this is
this is uh
the other thing that is true is that uh
mike oren who started pegasus news is
now
running
one of the most promising parts of our
business which is a content marketing
operation that he has put together
that helps businesses do
be on the internet
and
and so
i will say to a certain extent pegasus
news is saving the business of the
dallas morning news because uh
we that the real reason we bought um
we bought pegasus was to aqua hire mike
uh
lunch break any other